I don't know where hi we just hear big
shotgun
we just we stop what we're doing and
then it just keeps going that happened
and we just grabbed each other we
started running and unfortunately I was
shot about three times in my leg so I
had fallen down I tried to get back up
but everyone started running everywhere
I got trampled over and I shattered and
broke my bones on my left leg so by this
time I couldn't walk at all all I could
do was just lay down there where
everyone was just running on top of me
trying to get to where they had to be
and um all I could hear was the shotgun
one after another and people screaming
people yelling for help by this time
this man he goes into the other room and
I can just hear more shotguns going on I
thought I was a little safe at this time
because you know it's giving everyone
time to tackle him down or get him down
but unfortunately I hear him come back
and he's shooting everyone that's
already dead on the floor making sure
they're dead I was able to peek over and
I can just see him shooting at everyone
and I can hear the saw the shotguns
closer and I look over and he shoots the
girl next to me and I'm just there
laying down I'm thinking I'm next I'm
dead so I don't know how but by the
glory of God he shoots towards my head
but it hits my hand and then he shoots
me again and hits lob the side of my hip
I had no reaction I was just prepared to
just stay there laying down so he won't
know that I'm alive and he's just doing
this for another five ten minutes he's
just shooting all over the place
by this time he goes up to the front and
I think that's when he's battling
against the cops I just hear shotguns
going all over the place
and I'm looking up in some cops which I
wish I can remember his face or his name
cuz I'm to say I'm grateful for him he
lets up me he make sure that then I'm
alive and he grabs my hand and he's like
this is the only way I can take you out
I'm like please carry me because I'm in
pain right now I couldn't walk or
anything so he died he starts to drag me
out across the street to Wendy's and I'm
grateful for him but the floor is just
covered in glass so he's dragging me out
while I'm just getting cut my behind my
back my legs and I don't feel pain but I
just feel all this blood on me from
myself from my other people and he just
drops me off across the street and I
look over and there's bodies everywhere
we're all in pain